this is a world-famous ghost pepper
there's more beans right these are the
Carolina Reapers yeah and they are the
world-famous a number one the artist a
paper on the planet we're gonna put the
coin on this are you sure we're gonna
leave it up to fate okay heads
definitely stick in the wings
with going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans coming a trip from
Jimmy's 43 in the East Village and I'm
joined by chili Klaus and this is the
first time we've met yeah but I already
feel like we're friends that's a good
career for those of you who don't know
chili Klaus is the Michael Jordan of hot
chilies if hot Chili's had a Mount
Rushmore before
faces of chili Klaus you're a legend
okay and one of my favorite videos that
you ever did was one where you were the
conductor of a symphony and you had
everybody eat peppers before they
started playing and that was the
funniest video I've ever seen I thought
I would add a little extra passion to
the music and I think I've succeeded
with that do you think the peppers
helped the music music is a filled with
passion and if you have played the same
tune again and again maybe that they
need a little extra - some flavors yes
employment yeah yeah exactly what about
other people have you seen because we
have on our show we've seen people cry
we've seen people have to get up and
walk around we've seen rappers hardcore
rappers just bow out like little babies
and have to leave what about with you
what's some of the worst things you've
ever seen I had a local mayor who
visited me and we did it twice because
politicians they know when they said
from in front of a camera never cry
never do anything just to stick to your
to your case and the second time he went
to gay he started puking yeah so so it
was a great fun and you know what I find
as an interview technique is it doesn't
seem like it would work but it does so
with our show every question you know
has its own wing and as we get further
along in the show the spicier the food
gets the more in pain they are they're
actually more likely to give you more
information than they otherwise would
because they're not thinking about their
guardrails they're not thinking about
the hands that they're supposed to play
close to the vest and they end up just
giving me everything that I want for
free do you find that to be the same
exactly
exactly the thing I think all people
have kind of shields in front of them
because when there is a camera they know
they smile and they do the normal stuff
the heavy shoes and when they eat a
pepper the shoes fill down and you see
the real person behind of you let me
read off some of these side effects
freak-outs
crying turning colors oh hi
similar to a narcotic there could well
story okay I've never tried that but I'm
looking forward if you were to tell a
little bit about let's talk yes these
are like ghost chilies right these ones
and I should mention that these are cut
these peppers and the point of all this
is season two of hot ones is coming at
you and it's coming at you quick this is
like my offseason training this is so
when I get those wings in front of me
none of them can stop me because these
three peppers are crazy yeah
chili Klaus tell me they're crazy right
they're all way way way way way way
hotter than our hottest wing and I gotta
be honest with you I'm very very scared
right now
so let's break these down as far as I've
been so this is a the world-famous ghost
pepper also called booty Rokia which
originally from India and they use it in
India to keep the elephants from the
inner jungle because they go out in the
rice fields and playing around and and
the farmers don't want that so they put
this on the fence and the elephant comes
out oh this is hot out here and then it
runs into the jungle and no problems
with elephants in India because of this
so this little thing scares enormous
elephants off of farmland but the two
idiots sitting over here just gonna
might snack on it might eat it like a
sentiment I'm much clearer than we much
more evolved what's this one this one's
the these are scorpions right in
Trinidad where they originally
cultivated they use they don't eat them
it's way too hard for the trend that
people and oh no no no they advise them
and put them in into paint a paint
fallen ships underneath the ships so
they don't have problems with the Sphinx
growing underneath boats so these were
like yeah the very they have very fast
boats infinite because of this Jupiter
so this chili pepper will make it like
it'll actually halt
another biology's you know so it'll get
lost an entire habitat yeah exactly
that's what I'm showing but they they
are very tasteful and they have a very
nice flavor yeah we'll see about that
simple scene and then this last one
these are the Carolina Reapers yeah and
they are the world famous number one the
hottest people on the planet and am i
right you have bought them from smoking
it are they so we bought it I'm right we
bought these from pucker but in Fort
Mill South Carolina and for the people
who don't know that guy's like a mad
scientist crazy guy yeah you know I
don't know him but I know I know him but
yeah yeah
he said yes this a yeah he's a scientist
in a way and he grows these insanely hot
peppers and like most mad scientists
he's not going to make a more friendly
version of the product he's going to
make a monster version of the product so
here we have Carolina Reapers the
hottest pepper in the world but probably
that version on steroids like we have a
monster version of the hottest pepper
right here do you feel pain yet just so
cool what do you do to deal with it some
people think that it's all in your mind
that's what I try to tell myself
that's what work you know no no it
doesn't that's because I'm weak minded
but what about you I'm weak minded too
but I've tried it so many times so I
know what what I'm going through but
actually today it's
in more than a week since I've even that
chilly so I'm a bit rusty
so I well take these ghost chilies out
because they're like the weakest of what
we have here right so we'll just have
these two does anybody have a coin heads
yeah we'll eat the scorpions tails will
eat the Carolina Reapers yeah okay heads
scorpions thank God I think with a
butcher peachy really yeah yeah I think
so and I'm to fall I'm going to fold it
loose
this is a TV show so we do it the big
way Chris Schoenberger from first we
feast
full disclosure was like just for the
love of God don't eat the Carolina
Reapers because you might die yeah
so these are the Carolina Reapers
hottest pepper in the world and probably
even hotter than the hottest pepper
because we bought them off of a mad
scientist
hahaha yeah what the mad scientist mmm
smell it's very very tasteful and I
don't know this Rashaad it's very very
tasteful and and and it's fruity fat
fighters will it mmm that makes me
nervous
no no no no no no no no remember
remember to choose because if you don't
choose very well it will be hurt in your
stomach
yeah it's very important that you at
least 10 times in a month okay I'll be
forced to swallow it remember that
that's very important you ready yeah
Cheers
hmm it's very truthful
yeah
Wow
oh yeah you like it yeah great but yeah
great pepper is this holy [ __ ] is that
as hot as you'll go whoa this is very
hot yeah I think it's a little bit more
hot that my Scandinavian
cousins but that it's very taste taste
for two and you can also feel it it in
New Year's you know in my neck okay Wow
Oh Shawn yeah what do you think about
top yeah as much pain as I'm Benin in a
while yeah
Wow this is what we go through
stay tuned for season 2 yeah definitely
stick into wings nothing this good yeah
yeah really nice meeting you chilly
o'clock let me show you your whoa say
hello to Shawn are living proof that is
very tough to run to one engine a
channel ah
Wow look I Love You Man
let me do not emit Wow Wow whoa
everything is hotter in New York it is
yeah hotter in New York yeah what
happens we come to my city chili Klaus
yeah oh that's cool
whoo oh all right so we got ten wings
ten questions it's not the Olympics
people always like to have to eat the
whole thing just take a bite okay I
asked you the question ruminate on it
move on to the next one right now hear
this yep just cuz I don't give a [ __ ] I
can't even hear what you're saying so my
mouth is on fire
yes doing things for yourself you know
really sad right I then just stop people
say blood guys have big dicks I mean you
know I did a lot of payless Shoe Store